welcome everybody it's a great pleasure
for me to have the opportunity to
introduce Michael Walzer to give the for
the Stimson lectures here at Yale in
2013 my name is Ian Shapiro as some of
you know and now you all do I'm not
known for my long introductions but I
will have to say a couple of personal
things about Michael before I allow him
to to start but I should just say that
the Henry L Stimson lectures are named
for Henry Stimson class of 1889 who was
Secretary of War during World War two
and otherwise a distinguished statesman
the lecture series was actually named
for him and funded by some anonymous
donors and they have been very
distinguished lectures given in the
series in the past including by Samuel
Huntington Thomas Schelling and more
recently John Donne and we're really
delighted to have Michael Walzer here to
give his four lectures on the general
subject of what happened to national
liberation
nobody is here to listen to me and I
will just say a few things and then and
and then disappear but I do need to say
that many people here know of Michael's
enormous distinction and influence in
the world of political philosophy he's
his Revolution and the saints which put
him on the map at a very young age and
his work on just and unjust Wars when I
when I came of age as a young obnoxious
political theory graduate student in the
1980s is when Michael was writing about
justice and there was virtually no
political philosophy at Yale in those
days and he had made the move from
Harvard to the Institute for Advanced
Study at Princeton a few years earlier
and I was this kind of floundering
graduate student about 23 or 24 years
old and the worst thing about being a 23
or 24 year old graduate student is that
you're in great need of advice and
completely unwilling to listen to it and
I certainly I think had both those
traits although Michael probably too
nice to two to have dwelled on them but
he took me on long distance he had no
obligation to do that and actually saw
me through my my graduate student years
and I will always be grateful for that I
don't think I'd be standing here today
without the help that Michael gave me in
those years so it's really a distinct
personal pleasure and great honor for me
to be able to invite Michael for the
first of his lectures today thank you
well it's obviously true that I would
not be standing here were it not for Ian
I am I am committed to four lectures and
I hope that they hang together my
project in these lectures is to describe
a recurrent and to my mind disturbing
pattern in the history of national
liberation I will be discussing a very
small set of cases the creation of three
independent states in the years after
World War two India and Israel
immediately after and Algeria roughly
fifteen years later and I'm going to
focus on the political movements that
achieve their independence in this first
lecture sketching the the general
argument I will refer to all three
movements the Indian National Congress
labor Zionism and the Algerian FLN the
National Liberation Front but chiefly to
the FLN I will also refer because it's
been a general reference for Western
writers about revolution and national
liberation and also because I've written
about it to the exodus of the ancient
Israelites from Egypt which is arguably
the earliest example in literature if
not in history of the liberation of a
nation from foreign rule in my second
lecture tomorrow I will examine the
recurrent pattern in detail in the case
that I know best the Zionist movement
and the state it created in the third
lecture I will consider an alternative
view of the three cases defended
primarily by Marxist writers and also
especially in India by scholars in
post-colonial studies and in the fourth
lecture I will ask whether National
Liberation has a future looking first
and most extensively at India and then
again at Israel I won't pretend that the
pattern I'm going to describe is
universal or that it is precisely the
same in all its iterations I follow the
maxim about political life that nothing
is the same as anything else but some
things are similar to other things and
comparisons can help us understand both
the similarities and the differences
my aim is understanding not scientific
explanation the three case pattern can't
be expressed as a set of covering laws
because there are many cases that the
laws wouldn't cover and even these three
can each be described in ways that would
greatly complicate my schematic account
but my account will enable me to raise
some large questions about the cultural
reproduction of the secular
liberationists left and about its
encounter with religious fervour
initially at least National Liberation
is a success story the three nations
were indeed liver
from foreign rule at the same time
however the states that now exist are
not the states envisioned by the
original leaders of the national
liberation movements one difference is
central and I will keep coming back to
it all three movements were secular
committed indeed to an explicitly
secularists project and yet in the
states that they created a politics
rooted in what we can call
fundamentalist religion is today very
powerful this unexpected outcome is part
of what I mean by the paradox of
national liberation consider the
original Enterprise National Liberation
is an ambitious and also from the
beginning and ambiguous project because
the nation has to be liberated not only
from external oppressors in a way that's
the easy part
but also from the internal effects of
external oppression one of these effects
is the power of traditional elites the
mediators of foreign rule I mean the men
and women mostly men who move back and
forth between the subject nation and its
rulers negotiating with the rulers
bribing them when necessary
accommodating their demands when that
seems necessary making the best of a
difficult and often humiliating
relationship the figure of the court Jew
has parallels in every nation ruled by
foreigners and one of the aims of
national liberation is the elimination
of that role and the defeat of the
people who made it their own but there
is another even more important effect of
external oppression that has to be
overcome and that is the passivity the
quietude the deep lethargy of the
dominated people no nation can live for
long under foreign rule or like the Jews
in exile without accommodating to its
condition and making its peace with the
powers that be the accommodation will be
more or less profound
depending on the severity of the
conditions that have to be accommodated
and the number of years or decades or
centuries during which those conditions
prevail in the sphere of politics
accommodation takes a variety of forms
fatalistic resignation withdrawal from
political activity to familial or
communal concerns even an acceptance of
the political superiority of the foreign
rulers in this latter case the local
culture is reconceived
as somehow unsuited to politics devoted
to higher more spiritual pursuits they
the British the French Europeans
generally have a talent for politics
they have the ruthlessness necessary for
imperial domination we submit because we
are focused on more important things
ruthlessness is alien to us even
liberationists like Gandhi who don't
want to imitate the ruthlessness of
Imperial rulers as many others do
believe nonetheless that it is necessary
as Gandhi wrote to train the masses in
self-consciousness and the attainment of
power his constructive program was aimed
at producing men and women who did not
yet exist in the India he knew who were
fit for independence capable of managing
their own affairs this was a task that
should rightly have preceded national
liberation but was in all my cases
unfinished at the moment when
independence was one from the beginning
it encountered difficulties once people
have settled in and adjusted themselves
one way or another to a particular
version of foreign rule the men and
women who suddenly appear and offered to
liberate them are likely to be regarded
with suspicion as Moses was when he
tried to explain to the Israelites that
they were about to be delivered from
Egyptian slavery here the biblical text
tells a classic story which is repeated
again in the
when young and enthusiastic liberators
first encounter the people they mean to
liberate and find them frightened and
reluctant the liberators quickly
discover that they need in in modern
terms to raise the consciousness of the
people before liberation is possible and
what can this mean except to oppose the
people's already existing consciousness
which has been shaped by oppression and
accommodation raising consciousness is a
persuasive enterprise but it quickly
turns into a cultural war between the
liberators and let's call them the the
traditionalists this can be a very tense
business it's possible for a casual
charismatic leader like Gandhi to adapt
the traditional culture to the needs of
national liberation but adaptations of
this sort are likely to encounter fierce
opposition their success may well be
brief
Gandhi was deeply opposed to many
aspects of Hindu culture the fate of the
Untouchables most importantly he was
assassinated by someone committed to a
more literal or narrow or perhaps
fundamentalist version of Hinduism I've
taken this example and all my examples
from the history of nationalism but I
want to stress that national liberation
is a subset of that history a piece of
it not the whole of it indeed the
liberationist project seems somewhat at
odds with Webster's definition of
nationalism which goes like this a sense
of national consciousness exalting one
nation above all others and placing
primary emphasis on promotion of its
culture and interests as opposed to
those of other nations
there are certainly men and women with
this sort of consciousness in all the
national liberation movements but the
primary emphasis of the movements
leaders is doubly different first they
aim to achieve political independence
and equality with other nations
and second they aim to liberate their
own nation from longstanding traditions
of authoritarianism and passivity
liberation is actually closer to
revolutionary politics than to national
aggrandizement like the liberationist
militants revolutionary set themselves
in opposition to establish patterns of
submission and accommodation and what
they call false consciousness and they
aim at a radical transformation social
revolution requires a struggle against
the actually existing society national
liberation requires a struggle against
rather than an exaltation of the
actually existing nation it is also
often an anti religious struggle for
religion as jawaharlal nehru wrote
teaches quote a philosophy of submission
to the prevailing social order and to
everything that is Nehru is repeating
here the standard liberationist view
which follows from the fact that the
accommodation to foreign rule commonly
takes religious forms in part for the
obvious reason that other worldliness
offers comforts that are always
available but the secular militants of
national liberation are mistaken if they
describe the comforts of religion as
nothing more than pie in the sky
religion also generates fantasies of a
reversal and triumph and then
intermittently revivalists and
millenarian movements which are
sometimes tumultuous but always
ineffective millenarianism looks like
opposition to foreign rule and maybe
that briefly but over the long run it is
another form of political accommodation
for it doesn't produce a persistent
oppositional politics and the millennium
never arrives there is also another more
concrete form of religious accommodation
which doesn't look forward to
apocalyptic events most religions
prescribe a this worldly regimen
that cannon should be established right
now which requires submission from
ordinary believers and assigns an
authoritative role to traditional
religious leaders who are often already
officials and judges appointed by and
submissive in their turn to foreign
rulers but neither a millenarian nor
traditionalist politics invites
ideological commitment or long-term
activism nor does it promise individual
freedom political independence
citizenship democratic government
scientific education or economic advance
it's for the sake of all these that the
National Liberation Astoria Lucien Airy
militants need to transform the people
in whose name they are acting and that
means to defeat the people's religious
leaders and overcome their customary way
of life VS Naipaul writing 30 years
after indian national liberation
perfectly captures the attitude of the
liberators toward the religion of their
people and I'm quoting now Hinduism has
exposed us to a thousand years of defeat
and stagnation it has given men no idea
of a contract with others no idea of a
state it has enslaved one quarter of the
population and always left the whole
fragmented and vulnerable its philosophy
of withdrawal has diminished men
intellectually and not equipped them to
respond to challenge it has stifled
growth national liberation by contrast
is a secularizing modernizing and
developmental Creed it is its opponents
rightly say a Western Creed and to the
nation about to be liberated it is
entirely new indeed newness is the
mantra of the liberators they offer the
oppressed people a new beginning in new
politics a new culture a new economy
they aim to create new men and women
thus David ben-gurion the most important
contribution that the labor Zionists
movement has made is not the new
ideology but the creation of a new kind
of man and similarly Frantz Fanon there
is a new kind of algerian man the power
of the Algerian revolution resides in
the radical mutation that the Algerian
has undergone of course this newness
encounters resistance which begins as a
stubborn allegiance to the way things
have always been
but soon becomes ideological and
therefore also new fundamentalism and
ultra-orthodox er both modernist
reactions to attempts at modernist
transformation the slogan of Jewish
ultra orthodoxy everything new is
forbidden by the Torah is itself a new
idea it would have made the historic
accommodation to exile impossible Jewish
survival required a lively adaptability
and a readiness for innovation but the
slogan works well against the temps to
bring the exile to an end and one can
find similar examples of opposition to
the newness of national liberation in
India and Algeria what is more
surprising is the reappearance of this
opposition after the achievement of
political independence when the
defenders of traditional religion
themselves renewed and modernized begin
the construction of a counter
revolutionary politics I had better tell
a particular story now so as to avoid to
schematic an account I will begin with
the Algerian case because it is in some
ways the outlier among my three the
commitment to secular liberation though
it finds an avid spokesman in Frantz
Fanon is weaker here than in India and
Israel the dominant movement in the
Algerian struggle was the FLN whose most
visible leaders who were indeed secular
and Marxist or at least socialists in
their political commitment but the
initial manifesto of the FL
read over Cairo radio in 1954 called for
quote an Algerian state sovereign
democratic and social within the
framework of the principles of Islam
there were many people in the FLN who
took this framework seriously and who
demanded after independence that it be
put in place in the early years however
FLN militants displayed little interest
in Islamic principles and the Summa
platform of 1956 the work primarily of
the internal FLN and its Berber leaders
actually left the principles of Islam
out of its description of the movements
goal the birth of an Algerian state in
the form of a democratic and social
Republic and not the restoration of
monarchy or of a theocracy in a French
prison
Achmed benbella the future first
president of Algeria read the leftist
publications of the Paris publisher
Maspero
and studied the works of Lenin Sartre
and malreaux Ramadan a B'nai one of the
ephah lens leading intellectuals and
later a defender of terrorism spent five
years in prison where he applied himself
I'm quoting from a historian of the
Algerian revolution - a voracious
reading of revolutionary studies Marx
and Lenin and even mine Kampf he had
already gained his baccalaureate he must
have done all his reading in French
many of the FLN militants and a larger
number of the intellectuals were
francophone the establishment of the
provisional government of the republic
of Algeria was announced in French by
Herod Abbas then the head of the FLN the
FL enters were certainly committed
algerian nationalists it's not with you
but against you that we are learning
your language declares a character in a
novel by an Algerian writer who wrote in
French at the same time many of these
nationalists were culturally Francophile
or better
yura file ho scene 8
ComEd a Berber and along with benbella
one of the historic nine founders of the
FLN concentrated in his prison ears on
English novels though they aimed at
ending foreign rule militants like Ben
Bella and Achmed were remarkably at ease
in a foreign culture
by contrast Muslim moderates called upon
the French to allow the imposition of
Islamic family law in Algeria but given
that had no further difficulty with
French rule there already were Muslim
officials in Algeria who according to
the Summa platform were domesticated
chosen and paid by the colonial
administration these were some of the
immediate opponents of the FLN militants
whose political agenda included as the
writings of Fannin made clear not only
ending French rule but also overcoming
the colonial mentality and the Algerian
past FLN radicalism helps explain the
highly visible role that women were
given in the movement not in the
leadership a sign of things to come but
on the ground in military and terrorist
activities compare the role of women
among among Zionist militants especially
in the Hagana the military arm of the
Zionist movement putting women forward
in the FLN was not an affront to the
French oppressors it was directed
against the internal oppression of
Algeria's religious tradition fanon in
his portentous way makes this a central
theme quote the militant man discovers
the militant woman and jointly they
create new dimensions for algerian
society and again the freedom of the
algerian people is now identified with
women's liberation with her entry into
history and again in the movement the
woman ceased to be a mere complement of
the man
indeed might be said that she pulled up
her roots through her own exertions this
uprooting succeeded brilliantly for a
time but as contemporary algerian
politics attests it ultimately failed
alas Alastair Horne wrote in his 1977
history of the Algerian war the
promissory notes issued to women in the
heat of battle have yet to be fully
honored as of 2013 it seems fair to say
that they have hardly been honored at
all though the political standing of
Islam in Algeria today is contested its
cultural Authority is unquestionably
greater than FLN militants would have
predicted after 50 years of liberation
and the social standing of women in
Algeria today though also contested is
far short of the Equality that those
same militants promised their sisters in
the 1950s the FLN was a revolution in
the making resurgent Islam is the
counter-revolution truth to tell the
retreat from revolutionary feminism
began soon after the FLN victory in 1962
as horn suggests and it was confirmed in
the family code adopted in 1984 despite
the fierce opposition of many female
veterans of the liberation struggle the
new law made it a legal duty for
Algerian women to obey their husbands
institutionalized polygamy and denied
wives the right to apply for a divorce
unless they gave up all claims to
alimony still the Islamist zealots who
terrorized Algeria in the 1990s demanded
many more restrictions on the everyday
lives of women with regard to dress
mobility and employment one track of the
Islamic Salvation Front warned women
against using quote the Jewish word
emancipation to attack the Islamic
values of your
ancestors emancipation was of course one
of the central concepts of the early FLN
radicals it was central also to the
program of Indian national liberation
where it required a direct attack on the
religious culture and social practices
of both Hindus and Muslims when the
Indian Constitution was being debated
Rajkumari Amrit Cour
one of the founders of the All India
Women's Conference urged the drafting
committee can make sure that the
religious liberty clause in the new
constitution did not prohibit the wiping
out of religiously sanctified evils like
porta child marriage polygamy unequal
laws of inheritance the ban on inter
caste marriage and the dedication of
girls to temples tower who became
Minister of Health in Nehru his first
cabinet had been educated in the
Sherbourne School for Girls in Dorset
England and at Oxford University she was
in many ways a modern Western woman and
at the same time an Indian nationalist
and an early feminist there's nothing
unusual then in a francophone and even a
Francophile Algerian militant the
organizations that came together in 1885
to create the Indian National Congress
were dominated by Anglophone and
Anglophile lawyers journalists and
officials the architects of oppression
have a lot in common with the the
architects of liberation have a lot in
common with the architects of oppression
who were according to Marx's famous
articles on India the first
revolutionaries in Indian history the
liberationists have often gone to school
with the oppressors who commonly claim
to represent a more advanced culture
materially intellectually and of course
militarily Moses in Egypt is the classic
example raised in the palace of the
Pharaoh and certainly more at ease with
the Egyptian elite than with the people
hope to lead the training of the
liberator in the home country and
culture of the oppressor is a common
theme in the history of national
liberation Nehru spent eight years in
British schools Harrow Trinity College
Cambridge and the Inns of Court and as a
young man was more conversant with the
history and politics of Britain than
with the history and politics of India
late in his life he told the American
ambassador John Kenneth Galbraith I am
the last Englishman to rule in India BR
Ambedkar the untouchable lawyer neighbor
was first minister of justice studied
for the bar at Gray's Inn and did his
PhD work at the London School of
Economics tea rehearsal was another in
typical nationalist leader with a very
good Austrian education and no Jewish
education at all who knew far more about
other nations than about his own and who
was at home with the idea of Jewish
statehood because he was at home with
people who already had a state Franz
fanon received his medical and
psychiatric education in France and also
studied literature and philosophy there
none of the other leaders of the FLN
went to school in France but they
attended French lycée in Algeria and
many of them served in the French army
another kind of education benbella
received Frances highest military honour
and a kiss on each cheek from Charles de
Gaulle himself often the leaders of the
oppressed identified with an
oppositional ideology in the Imperial
country like the Marxism of some FLN
errs or another example the communism of
Ho Chi Minh also learned in Paris or the
Fabian socialism of Nehru and the Indian
National Congress or again the East
European social democracy of David
ben-gurion and ma Pi but the fact that a
doctrine was oppositional in say England
the
make it familiar in India here to the
militants of National Liberation are the
carriers of ideas that are utterly
unknown to the people or the greater
number of people to whom they are
carrying them what can they say to those
people they tell them that they are
oppressed because they are backward
passive mired in superstition and
ignorance unexposed to modern scientific
rationality to quote Nehru again led by
men who are the accomplices of
oppression
the militants raised the hope of newness
as I've said and give it body in one of
the modernists ideologies nationalist
liberal socialist or some combination of
those three they promised enlightenment
scientific knowledge and material
advance but perhaps more importantly
they promised victory over the
oppressors and equal standing in the
world they appeal especially to the
young they're usually very young
themselves and often urge a radical
break with family and friends they
demand total commitment to the movement
or perhaps a physical move to an
all-encompassing community like the
Zionist kibbutz
or a Gandhian village cooperative the
old ways must be repudiated and overcome
totally but the old ways are cherished
by many probably by most of the men and
women whose ways they are and that is
the paradox of liberation still the
liberators do win they lead a genuinely
national struggle against the foreign
rulers of their people once a vanguard
of militants has demonstrated that
victory is possible many men and women
who don't share the ideology of
liberation nonetheless join the struggle
the traditional political and religious
leaders are pushed to the side or they
withdraw about passivity is their style
or they go along with the liberators
accepting a marginal role the odd man
out in this schematic story
Gandhi who succeeded in turning
traditionalists passivity into a modern
political weapon
there's no comparable figure in Zionist
history or in or near the FLN or in any
other national liberation movement that
I know about even when he openly opposed
Hindu beliefs and practices Gandhi spoke
to the people in a religious language
that was largely foreign to the other
leaders of the national liberation
movement in 1934 for example he
suggested that an earthquake in Bihar
was divine punishment for the sin of
untouchability Nehru who would one day
help abolish untouchability was shocked
by what he called this staggering remark
anything more opposed to the scientific
outlook would be difficult to imagine
the two men managed to work together but
it was crucial to their cooperation that
Gandhi conceded the political succession
to the secularists and modernist Nehru
still secularists and modernists blame
Gandhi for the surprising strength of
religious nationalism in liberated India
thus VS Naipaul the drama the drama that
is being played out in India today is
the drama that Gandhi set up 60 years
ago Gandhi gave India its politics he
called up its archaic religious emotions
he made them serve one another and
brought about an awakening but in
independent India the elements of that
awakening negate one another no
government can survive on Gandhian
fantasy and spirituality the solace of a
conquered people which Gandhi turned
into a form of national assertion has
soured more obviously into the nihilism
that it always was that was written in
the late 1970s leftist intellectuals in
India these days are even more critical
of the Gandhian legacy I will come back
to their arguments in the third
of these lectures in Israel and Algeria
the transition from national liberation
to religious revival was accomplished
without the mediating role of a Gandhi
figure so perhaps Gandhi in India was
less central than his critics believe
perhaps Hindutva Hindu nationalism would
be a powerful force in Indian politics
even if he had never inspired and led
the liberation movement still the story
is harder to tell without him or without
anyone like him I don't mean that other
liberationist leaders were unwilling to
speak in religious terms
Zionists writers could hardly help but
invoke the sacred geography of the
biblical texts their hope for an
ingathering of the exiles was a
secularized version of a messianic
promise in Algeria the FL ins first
magazine was called el Mujahid this was
an embarrassment for Fannin who told his
readers that this phrase originally
meant a Muslim holy warrior but now
meant nothing more than a fighter
it was the common tie of Islam under the
pressure of colonial occupation writes
John Donne in his modern revolutions
that United Arab and Berber in their
rejection of the path of assimilation
still neither the strategy and tactics
nor the long-term political agenda of
the militants was significantly
influenced by their people's religion so
what happened the traditional seemed to
be defeated or marginalized the aura of
liberation didn't attach to them they
didn't have much influence in shaping
the constitutional arrangements the
economy or the educational system of the
new States they didn't make much of an
appearance in the new political elites
the story is more complicated in Algeria
where the radical left regime of
benbella lasted only three years who re
boumedienne who overthrew benbella in
1965 was certainly
no Francophile he had been educated in
Muslim schools in Algeria and had
studied at El Azhar University in Cairo
but the political leaders he most
admired were Castro and Tito he ran a
socialist economy which had always been
the promise of the FLN and sustained a
form of politics that while socially
conservative on issues like the status
of women would appear to the next
generation of Algerian Muslims as
radically secular how then was political
Islam how were the political versions of
Hinduism and Judaism sustained or
invented in the new world of liberation
in all three countries religion remained
a force in everyday life during the
years of liberation and it's aftermath
and nationalist leaders often found
religion useful for their immediate
political purpose which was to sustain
the unity of the anti-colonial struggle
in the new state though a few of the
militants might have liked to mount the
Bolshevik style attack on religion the
new rulers did not dare do that and in
any case they believed they all believed
that decline was the destiny of all
religions
what Nehru called the scientific outlook
was bound to triumph secularization did
not require radical coercion and it
allowed for temporary compromises
because it was an inevitable historical
tendency here is Nehru writing in the
Diskin in his book the discovery of
India in the 1930s some Hindus dream of
going back to the Vedas some Muslims
dream of an Islamic theocracy these are
idle fancies for there is no going back
to the past there is only one way
traffic in time the zionist perspective
was strikingly similar as the historian
a hood Lewis writes the assumption that
their Jewish religion was destined to
pass from the scene
sooner or later because it contradicted
the needs of modern life was accepted by
practically all the zionist
intelligentsia and that's more or less
what we all believed in those years and
for many years after or it's what almost
all of us believed my my friend and
colleague Clifford Gertz of the late
Clifford Gertz who studied nationalist
movements in both Indonesia and the Arab
world thought otherwise
writing about religion in Bali in the
new Indonesian state in the early 1960s
he argued that religious belief might be
swamped by modern materialist ideas but
probably not for quote such overall
drifts when they do not turn out to be
mirages altogether often pass over
deeply rooted cultural configurations
with rather less effect upon them than
we would have thought possible he went
further suggesting that today in Bali
some of the same social and intellectual
processes that gave rise to the
fundamental religious transformations of
world history seemed to be at least well
begun in other places to the drift or
perhaps we should call it the storm of
national liberation passed over ancient
societies and reborn nations with rather
less effect than the movements militants
expected and the processes that would
eventually lead to religious revival
were already begun under the eyes of the
militants but out of their sight the old
ways were sustained in temples
synagogues and mosques but also more
importantly in families in lifecycle
celebrations where the sustaining
behaviors were hardly visible to secular
militants busily at work on the big
projects of modernization indeed the
coming revivals were fueled by the
resentment that ordinary people pursuing
their customary ways felt toward those
secularizing and modernizing elites with
their foreign ideas they're patronizing
attitudes and their big projects they
were fueled even more by the
authoritarian or paternalist politics
that were forced upon the new a leets
in their war against the customary ways
the authoritarianism of the algerian
state was particularly brutal indeed the
internal politics of the FLN before
liberation was already murderous
reflecting deep tensions between arabs
and berbers as well as between
Francophile revolutionaries and more
locally based militants between the
exterior and the interior movements by
contrast the Indian National Congress
and the labor Zionists were committed to
democracy and mostly managed their
internal tensions in nonviolent ways but
even the leaders of these movements when
they exercise political power did so
with a sure sense that they knew what
was best for their backward and often
recalcitrant peoples and then the
backwardness came back and the democracy
that the liberation is created even in
Algeria briefly in 1990 and 91 was the
chief instrument of its return the
present crisis of liberal democracy in
India rights the political theorist
Rajiv Bhargava is due in large part to
its own success religious men and women
previously passive and inarticulate
entered the newly created public domain
bhargava says in numbers that greatly
exceeded the tiny upper crust that led
the national movement democratic
politics encouraged ethno-religious
political mobilizations
and the mobilised men and women did not
come he says from a cultural background
with a liberal or democratic character
but it wasn't the old backwardness that
these people or the politicians they
followed brought back religion appeared
now in militant ideological and
political forms modern even in its anti
modernism its protagonists claim to
embody the ancient
traditions the faith of the ancestors
even to represent a pure authentic
version of it
coldness is their mantra and though the
claim is false the sense of old nastain
they connect the liberated people to
their own past they provide a sense of
belonging and stability in a world
rapidly changing but what happened to
the Indian the Israeli and the Algerian
newness where are the new men and women
each the equal of the others standing
straight tall and smart I'm not sure how
to answer that question there are of
course a lot of people like that
National Liberation did reach beyond the
thin upper crust but nowhere near as
many as the liberationists expected it
appears that the culture of liberation
was too thin to sustain these people and
enable them to reproduce themselves the
radical rejection of the past left as it
were too little material for cultural
construction the liberators did generate
a set of holidays a set of heroes a set
of commemorative rituals they made up
songs and dances they wrote novels and
poems compare the French Revolution with
its new calendar it's neoclassical
revival its FETs and pageantry for a
while at least enough people seem to
engage with all these so that it was
almost possible to believe in the new
beginning but it was all too artificial
too recently constructed and after a
couple of generations that heroes lost
their aura the commemorations lost their
charm young people began to drift away
moving toward the excitement's of global
pop culture or turned toward the
fervency
of religious revival the attraction of
pop culture is no doubt a disappointment
to the aging militants of national
liberation but their biggest
disappointment their biggest surprise is
the large number of young men and women
who are drawn to the ideologies of
Hindutva Messianics
and ultra Orthodox Judaism and radical
Islam and aren't they right to be
surprised isn't it in fact unbelievable
that so many daughters of the women who
self uprooting and uncelebrated are
willingly rhe rooting themselves
returning to religious faiths that are
at least to this secular I as misogynist
as ever I suppose it isn't unbelievable
it's just the sort of thing social
science claims to explain Marxist
writers who are committed to scientific
explanation search for the social class
whose material interests religious
revival might serve a recent study of
left discourses in contemporary India
finds the rise of Hindutva attributed by
different writers to the petty
bourgeoisie the classic Marxist
candidate but also to the rich peasants
the poor peasants the limp and
proletariat the urban workers the old
brahmanas and the new capitalists I have
some sympathy with a despairing comment
that appeared in the leftist magazine
economic and political weekly in 1993
quote whatever the analytical
difficulties of reducing an ideology to
its material base unless one posited
such an epistemological relation one
will be left with a politically
debilitating agnosticism but the
reduction doesn't seem to work or at
least it needs more work two years later
the same writer in the same magazine
wrote that Hindutva isn't only quote an
instrumentality protecting a material
interest over and above that it is a set
of values attitudes and norms of
behavior that can only be countered with
the aid of alternative values and norms
that seems to me the beginning of
understanding I wouldn't give up on the
search for a material base Marxist
writers a right to look for the people
most likely to benefit from what the
political theorist VP Varma identifies
as the central goal of Hindu revivalism
the restoration of the Vedic principles
that require the functional organization
of society the old elites the upper
castes new capitalists patriarchs
everywhere these seem the obvious
beneficiaries still it's necessary to
acknowledge the populist appeal of
revivalism
the staying power of the old religion up
and down the social hierarchy without
that appeal the religious revival would
be of no use to the brahmanas the
capitalists and the patriarchs
countering the revival with a set of
alternative values and norms is not so
easy
doing it X Neil Oh seems pretty much
impossible but perhaps the militants of
national liberation like all
revolutionaries had to insist on radical
cultural negation and then on radical
newness perhaps that is the necessary
character of their project years ago
many years ago when I was writing about
the Puritan revolution in England I came
upon a sermon preached in the House of
Commons in 1643 that expresses a
sentiment common to revolutionaries
everywhere take heed of building upon an
old frame the preacher told the MPs an
old frame that must be all plucked down
to the ground take heed of plastering
when you should be pulling down the
difficulty is that such a radical
pulling down doesn't have enough appeal
to the people living in the house they
are too attached to it even if they
complain about its discomforts maybe
what is necessary is only a partial
demolition and a renovation of the rest
there actually were intellectuals in the
national liberation movements who aimed
at a critical engagement with the old
culture rather than a totalizing attack
upon it I like to think that had they
won out
the story might have turned out
differently the liberators might have
made their peace with at least some part
of their nations past fashioned a set of
beliefs and practices that were new
indeed but also familiar and thereby
avoided the extremism of religious
revival maybe I will want to argue
something like that but it's best to
begin with skepticism some commentators
insist that engagement was never
possible and then place their hopes in
the dialectic first comes the politics
of radical secularists rejection then
the politics of militant religious
reaffirmation and then as the OED says
the contradictions merge in a higher
truth that comprehends them both but the
dialectic doesn't seem to be working
these days the way it used to I don't
see many signs of the coming synthesis
in India Israel and Algeria and probably
in other places too the struggle that
the liberationist thought they had one
still has to be one it's going to
continue for a long time and its outcome
is as uncertain as it was at the very
beginning like the ancient Israelites
the modern militants thought they had
reached the promised land and then
discovered that they had carried Egypt
in their baggage
you